when we talk about the future of work
and we talk about
what would happen if we don't move
on diversity equity and inclusion i
don't
honestly think that there is a future
that that's possible studies have shown
that more diverse teams tend to perform
better
and many companies have made commitments
to hiring a more diverse workforce
yet creating inclusive work cultures
that are truly equitable and free of
bias
remains a formidable challenge for
companies especially since some of the
biggest obstacles
are the very employees they are trying
to change
one of the challenges uh in this space
is that people do have really strong
feelings about what they
should do and what's right but the
strategies that organizations have used
pretty much universally
are not effective they're ineffective
and sometimes make things worse
so many of us have incredible intentions
but terrible actions
and unless you can get your intention on
your action to align
then your intention is in vain but there
may be actions that companies and their
employees can take
that can mean change is finally starting
to happen
if business would step in and do this
work
i think it would change society outside
of the walls of business
and yes it is disruptive technology was
disruptive
think about the companies that said we
don't really want to touch technology
they're not here anymore
but from the disruption comes change
so there's a very strong link between
companies who
are strong at diversity equity and
inclusion and
increased organizational performance
this is dr david rock he's the ceo and
co-founder of the neuro leadership
institute
a consultancy company that advises
organizations on management strategies
based on science and evidence-based
practices
the most kind of salient way to
understand this is that
we all see the world very very
differently and
when you get a homogeneous team or a
team that's all basically the same
they actually make more cognitive errors
they don't see errors that other people
have made
and they're far less creative and far
less innovative than
a diverse team while these diverse
groups may be more efficient
creative and faster at finding and
solving problems
they often feel like they are being less
efficient and less confident in their
work
partly due to a phenomenon called
cognitive elaboration which is a long
word for
saying you're going to think harder the
teams are thinking harder
thinking is generally aversive and so we
we feel more confident and comfortable
in teams that are
more homogeneous where people basically
agree with us all the time
and it turns out that feels good but the
team is nowhere near as successful
if companies want to see the positive
effects of a diverse and inclusive
workforce
they need to find ways to mitigate that
naturally occurring friction
essentially they need to have their
employees be comfortable
being uncomfortable in business we go to
work we do our jobs and we leave
and we are so weary
of pushing against the grain with a
colleague with a co-worker with an
employer et cetera with an employee
and i think if we truly want to grow and
get to know each other better
we do have to embrace some of that
uncomfortable dialogue for the sake of
growth
this is former nfl linebacker and fox
sports analyst emmanuel acho
and in 2020 he launched a youtube series
all about getting
uncomfortable welcome to another episode
of uncomfortable conversations with a
black man
when's the last time you sat down just
to have a conversation
uh with a group of black people garrett
i can be honest with you i don't know
that i've ever had a conversation with a
group of black people
i created uncomfortable conversations
with a black man out of an overflow of
my heart
after the murder of george floyd i
realized i had to do something
the series would go on to amass over 17
million views
inspire two books and most recently
emmanuel launched a podcast with
accenture
north america ceo jimmy etheridge
so many ceos executives at companies
they want to serve
those under them or those with them but
they think they're doing what's best
but unless you ask them what is best you
will be sitting here
spitting your wheels and actually not
serving the person at all
primary example um jimmy and i recently
spoke to
a woman who was hearing disabled and we
started that conversation on that
episode
um i used words like um that she was
different
you know modified and all these other
fanciful words and but the first
question i asked
hey i'm going to start with this
disabled
is that wrong to say or not and she
actually told me she cringed when i said
different she said because she's not
different she is disabled and
and like she doesn't find any weakness
in that but she actually finds strength
in that
if i don't start with what is a very
uncomfortable question
i'm sitting here thinking i'm being
polite to try to
you know be kind and in all honesty
she's cringing on the inside
and that's what so many of us do in the
workplace well this is what i'm going to
do to make sure i help these black men
out
this is what i'm going to do to help out
these black women and so my advice is
talk to the people in whom you are
trying to serve
talk to the people in whom you are
trying to honor i had great intentions
my intentions were amazing by trying to
use a word that i perceived to be more
kind and disabled
my actions terrible in the last decade
or so
more businesses have promised to make
diversity a major priority
tech giants like apple google and
facebook
have committed to sharing their internal
diversity numbers and annual reports
and while there's been an increase in
the overall percentage of employees of
color at these companies
for some groups only minimal progress
has been made
when it comes to black or latinx
employees their percentage in the last
six years has only been raised one to
three percent
while hiring is only step one retaining
and growing diversity is a major focus
as well
and something that companies have also
struggled with just having bodies in the
building
doesn't get you anywhere you have to be
able to leverage that diversity
and that means you need systems you need
metrics you need accountability
this is janet stovall a veteran of the
corporate communications world and a
senior client
strategist for the neuro leadership
institute at nli we talk about
priorities
habits and systems so the first thing
you have to do
is you have to make this a priority and
it has to be a priority like any other
business priority
that a company decides that it wants to
pursue
then you have to look at the habits that
are in place
to make people either live up to those
priorities or not
and so once you prioritize you look at
the habits that are getting in the way
of that priority and then you build a
system to make sure that you can change
those habits
but according to nli research some of
the most common strategies that
companies turn to
in order to create inclusion can often
have the opposite effect
one example is in the area of
unconscious bias training
it feels really intuitive to mandate
you know like bias education you know
bias is clearly a problem
it seems perfectly logical to say well
look everyone should really go through
bias training
there's very good evidence that that
does nothing or makes things worse i
mean
you might get a program that gets small
amount of results but on
average requiring people to do
awareness-building bias training is not
going to help very much in 2016
researchers who study 30 years of data
from over 800 companies
wrote in the harvard business review
that the positive effects of diversity
training rarely last beyond a day or two
and a number of studies suggest that it
can activate bias
or spark a backlash now bias is
everywhere because
at the end of the day everybody is born
with bias
the problem is when bias gets into
business decisions
we sometimes make sub-optimal decisions
and
we we actually can't see the vast
majority of our own biases
no matter how much we want to or how
much we know about them but what we
realized is you could do something about
bias in
teams their strategy takes over 150
forms of bias
and groups them into five broad
categories
then instead of asking individuals to
self-police their own actions
companies can create systems to
encourage teams to get into the habit of
identifying biases as they happen
what we found is when you teach that to
people relatively quickly
people start to see these biases as they
happen
and relatively quickly they're able to
label bias in a process or in a decision
and then work out what to do to address
it and our studies are ongoing of course
in this space but we're seeing
about 78 of people who learn this
framework start to use it weekly at
least one to three times a week
it doesn't get us anywhere pointing the
finger
what we have to be able to do instead of
giving people labels is we have to be
able to label behaviors
if we can label behaviors and then agree
on a common language for those behaviors
we can talk about what people do
separate from what they
are so labeling people racist doesn't
help
in the business workplace it just
doesn't help at all but coming up with
things that help you
change the behavior that might be racist
behavior
that's what changes things
one of the most important things to do
with each and every individual
is is what we call find common ground
and
this is a habit of of creating in-group
with people
and and really bringing each of you into
the same
group in a sense um or in the brain it's
it's both of you being in this circle
that we all
draw around ourselves and being on that
same team
and so the habit is in every interaction
whether you're an employee or
a manager or leader in every interaction
you're really finding
common ground with that person ideally
creating
shared goals and this creates a really
strong sense of inclusion
i heard it said one time you know i
can't change hearts but i can change
laws
well i'd like to paraphrase that and say
you know i can't change what you
think but i can certainly change what
you do and as long as i change what you
do
i'll end up getting the results that i
want improving workplace diversity and
inclusion
isn't just about building one set of
habits or eliminating a certain behavior
and it is likely to be uncomfortable but
if the future of work can truly leverage
diverse and inclusive cultures
it can have effects beyond just the
company's bottom line
i truly believe that the business
workplace
is the only place that some people ever
come into contact with anybody who's
different from them
we can spend our lives around people who
are no different from us
outside of work all we want but if we go
to work
and if you have an organization that
decides it is committed
to diversity equity and inclusion and it
is committed enough
that it is going to have priorities
habits and systems
in place to make that grow and be
what it needs to be you have a choice if
you work in that environment you're
either going to get on with it or you're
not
and so i think the business is the one
entity
that could actually change this because
no place else
has that reach no place else has that
context
no place else has the power the money
and the resources
to change things than the commercial
world and so if we step into this and do
this work i think it'll change society